[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de
mo
blanc
[Musique]
bénédiction pour
fa mais malheureusement toute la mi on
Le Non
Non Non
[Musique]
Non mal pour la
ven
mauvais pour la vie dans
[Musique]
le e
dans
[Des rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur samuel fontaine s'il vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plt
[Musique]
pas va des doigts dans la terar soit
veronique oui ma un avant le
son stéréo con est le ch
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Li si c'est un dernier paragraphe pour
commencer un nouvel art
Cici c
lesis
un
[Musique]
unique
c'est pour
ma malia pour la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
min
pour la vie même dans la mort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mal
Non